[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه الكرام
تقريبا مع سوريا
يقطع الاف الكيلو مترات ليتمركزوا شمال
سوريا
والحركات الارهابيه التي تقدم مضاجعها منذ
عقود الا يبدو الرئيس التركي مصمم هذه
المره على اطلاق عمليه عسكريه بريه في
الشمال السوري
لكن في المقابل الا تعلن تركيا عن مثل هذه
العمليه منذ اشهر واشهر اليست مجرده جعجعه
بلا طحين اليست انقره عجزه عن شني اي
عمليه بعمق 30 كلم رغما عن انفي امريكا
وروسيا واسرائيل هل يستطيع الاتراك ان
يقدموا على اي عمل عسكري شمال سوريا او
شرقها دون ضوء اخضر امريكيا بدرجه الاولى
الا توجه تركيا اليوم معارضه شديده من
الامريكيين والروس الم يفشل الرئيس التركي
حتى في عقد لقاء مع الرئيس السوري لتامين
الحدود بين الطرفين الا تواجه تركيا ايضا
معارضه ايرانيه شديده لاي توغل تركي في
الاراضي السوريه اسئله اطرحها هنا في
الاستوديو على حمزه تكن رئيسه تحرير وكاله
انباء تركيا وعبر الاقمار الصناعيه من
لندن على الخبير بشان التركيه غسان
ابراهيم
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره ثانيه الكرام نحن معكم في
برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس غسان ابراهيم لو
بدات معك في او من لندن
هذه المره يبدو ان التهديدات التركيه بشني
عمليه عسكريه واسعه النطاق في شمال سوريا
ضد الفصائل الكرديه ولتطهير المنطقه من كل
الحركات التي تهدد الامن القومي التركي
يبدو ان هذه التهديدات هذه المره ليست
كسبقاتها العمليه اصبحت على نار حاميه في
سلسله عوجل على الجزيره مصدر تركي رسمي
للجزيره اعطينا مهله لوشنطن و موسكو
لاخراج قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من منبج
وتل رفعت وعين العرب عاجل اخر مصدر تركي
لن نمدد المهله الزمنيه والبديل عن خروج
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه عمليه عسكريه مصدر
تركي واشنطن طرحت اعاده هيكله قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وابعاد الاسماء التي تتحفظ
عليها تركيا واخيرا مصدر تركي الجانب
الامريكي اقترح منحى دور اكبر للمكون
العربي في اداره منبج وتل رفعت وعين العرب
يبدو ان الاطراف التي كانت معارضه وخاصه
امريكا والروس وغيرهم بدا التالين اذا
عمليه عسكريه وشيكه كيف ترد
يا دكتور هذا هذا الكلام والاخبار التي
ذكرتها عن مصدر تركي يعني اكيد المصدر
التركي ما حيقول انه امريكا قالت لا
للتركيا اكيد ما حيقول انه الامريكي جعل
التركي يهدد على الفاضي يصل له اشهر عم
نسمع من تركيا ومن اردوغان عمليه وشيكا
عمليه وشيكه يعني كلمه وشيكه صار بدها
اعاده صياغه يعني شو معناتها وشيكا يعني
بعد كم يوم او بعد كم ساعه مو هيك بعد كم
شهر يعني بغض النظر اذا حتصير هذه العمليه
بعد كذا سنه او حتصير بعد كذا شهر هذا
يؤكد ان التركي عم يطر يعيد بسياسته ويقدم
تنازلات لحتى يسمح له بالقيام بمثل هذه
العمليه تركيا واردوغان كل التصريحات التي
صدرت عنهم ادت الى تراجع بمواقف اردوغان
اعطيك امثله وامثله لا تعاد اردوغانم
زمانه نزل الطائره التركيه اسقط طائره
تركيه بعد ذلك ذهب الى الروس روسيه
طائره روسيه اسقط طائره روسيه وليست تركيه
طائره روسيه بعد من ذهب الى الروس لعن
بوتين يترجى ويعتذر نفس الشيء دعم الاخوان
المسلمين وصعد ضد مصر ذهب الى مصريين
يصافح السيسي ويعتذر صعد مع مع الدول لبعض
دول الخليج قدم لها تنازلات في سوريا وقف
ضد الاسد و سوف اسقط الاسد وسوف ندعم
ونعمل وكذا فاذا به يتخلى عن المعارضه
وينقلب على المعارضه ويذهب ليبدا صفحه
جديده مع الاسد كل ذلك من اجل ان يقوم
بعمليه عسكريه حدوديه يعني لو كانت تركيا
بالقوه العسكريه التي يتحدثون عنها لكن
بامكانها ان تدخل 30 كيلو متر يعني 30
كيلو متر بجائش هو عضو بالنايته لو كان له
زعيم قوي لا فعل ولكن تركيا اليوم بقياده
اردوغان بلد بدون استراتيجيه بلد
التناقضات تسرح بشيء تتراجع عنه بعدها
قالوا انهم سوف يقفوا مع الربيع العربي ضد
الزعماء العرب واذا باردوغان اليوم يصافح
كل الزعماء العرب الذين هددهم وادعى انه
سوف يقف مع شعوبه مع الشعوب العربيه ضدهم
رجل ليس لديه الرؤيه واضحه الرجل قائم على
التناقضات رجل برجماتي من ناحيه من طريقه
ليس احترافيه من طريقه بدون قياميه يعني
هو جاء من حزب اسلامي قال انه سوف يقف مع
قيام الشعوب واذا به يتخلى عن كل الشعوب
بما في يوم الشعب التركي يعني عندما وصل
الى تركيا للحكم قال انه سوف يحل الازمه
الكرديه واذا به اليوم اهم عدو له من شعب
الكردي تمام همه اليوم مقاتله الكرد
يقول انه يريد ده بس شغله واحده بسوريا
يقول انه يريد ان يحمي الامن القومي
التركي من من هو وقف مع داعش داعش كانت
تسرح وتمرح بتركيا تاتي من تركيا الى
سوريا لم يقلق من على الامن القومي من
الدواعش هو قال من الوجود الكردي يعني
لديه نزع عنصريه ومشكله مع الاكراد يا اخي
صفيها بتركيا نحن شو دخلنا بسوريا همم
يعمل لها الازمه هذه بسبب عقدته مع
الاكراد رجل قائم على هاستيريا تجاه الكرد
وصلت الفكره
الاعضاء
في السجون في مشكلته هناك
وصلت الفكره همزتك كيف ترد على هذا الوابل
من الهجوم يعني اي هجوم دكتور فيصل موضوع
انا اتيت الى هنا الى هذا الاستديو موضوع
الحلقه العمليه العسكريه التركيه وليس
اردوغان يعني موضوع الحلقه ليس اردوغان ما
تفضل به هذا
لا اعرف اسمه نسيت اسمه من لندن يعني
يتحدث كل الحديث عن اردوغان انت سالته عن
العمليه العسكريه التركيه ولم يجب انا
ساجيبك على هذه القضيه العمليه العسكريه
التركيه قادمه اليوم سواء شاء الامريكي او
لم يشا الامريكي لماذا انا اقول هذا
الكلام وبكل قوه وبكل ثقه هذه تجارب سابقا
لدينا تجارب سابقا نحن لا نتحدث شعارات
واحلام كما يتحدث الضيف من لندن لدينا
عمليات عسكريه تركيه سابقه نفذها الجيش
التركي في الشمال السوري رغم المعارضه
الامريكيه والمعارضه الروسيه انا اتمنى
اليوم ان تقوم العمليه درع الفراد
وانا اتمنى ان تبقى امريكا معارضه للعمليه
المقبله وان تبقى روسيا معارضه للعمليه
المقبله واسرائيل اثناء اسرائيل في
المنطقه كي تقوم تركيا بالعمليه عن قوه
وليس عن مجرد حوار سياسي ضيفك يدعي ان
اليوم التركي لم يقل ان امريكا يعني هي
تعارض وزير الدفاع التركي وتصريح موجود
قبل 24 ساعه قال ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعارض العمل العسكري ونحن بحوار
معها لا تخجل تركيا بقول الحقيقه وقول ما
يجري في الكواليس مع الجانب الامريكي
والجانب الروسي كلمه وشيكا التي قالها نعم
هي وشيكه ونحن منذ سنه نقول العمليه وشيكه
وفي هذه الحلقه وفي حلقه سابقه قلنا انها
شيكا لماذا نقول وشيكا لماذا يقول الرئيس
اردوغان والحكومه التركيه ان العمليات
ستكون على حين غره على حين يغره هنا القوه
العسكريه هنا اللعبه السياسيه التي يلعبها
اردوغان ولن يقول الحكومه التركيه نحن
سناتي بعمليه في التاريخ الفلاني والساعه
الفلاني على الاطلاق العمليه ستكون مباغته
في ليله ليس فيها الضوء قمر
الجيش التركي مصمم على تنفيذ العمليه
العسكريه وهذا ليس كلامي وليس اردوغان
وليس كلام الحكومه التركيه هذا كلام زعيم
التنظيم الارهابي بيكاكا بيدي قصد مظلوم
عبد هذا الشخص قبل ساعات قال ان الجيش
التركي مصمم وحلفاؤنا في روسيا وامريكا
تخلوا عنه قضيه دعم تركيا للتنظيمات
الارهابيه وداعش هذه النغمه سمعناها كثيرا
وباطله بكل تاكيد بالارقام دعني اقول لك
ماذا فعلت تركيا بتنظيم داعش الارهابي فقط
خلال هذا العام يعني ما نتحدث عن الاعوام
السابقه
توقيف
2262 عنصر من تنظيم داعش الارهابي
والتواريخ مسجله بالارقام في في جرابلس في
الباب في برسيم فيها طاي في بولو في منطقه
نبع السلام في اسطنبول عشرات من هؤلاء
العناصر تم توقفهم من قبل الامن التركي
وبالتالي زريعه ان تركيا تدعم التنظيمات
الارهابيه هذه اصبحت واهيه تركيا حيدت
حيدت 792 قيادي من هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه منذ العام 2016 اي ان تركيا
تحارب التنظيمات الارهابيه وزعيم ناتو
زعيم الناتو خرج عده مرات وشكر تركيا انها
تحارب التنظيمات الارهابيه وعلى راسها
داعش اصدق الناتو رغم خلافه معه في بعض
النواحي ام ام ام مصدق مجرد كلام يخرج من
لندن مرسل لا قيمه له بدليل ولا برقم
العمليه العسكريه قادمه وانا استطيع ان
اقول لك بالخريطه اين ستكون وبالارقام اما
التوقيت في هذا التسميحك عذرا يبقى لدى
هذا التركيه سيتكون مفاجئه وقويه بالضربه
الاولى العمليه ستشمل بل رفعت بالدرجه
الاولى عين العرب ومنبج لماذا هذه المناطق
الثلاثه لان تركيا تريد ان تصل ادلب
وعفرين ونبع السلام ودرع الفرات وغسل
الزيتون وبالتالي تصبح منطقه كبيره امنه
يعود لها ملايين اللاجئين السوريين
لمدونهم لقراهم وتنهض الحياه هناك
وبالتالي تتحقق مصلحه تركيا باقامه
المنطقه الامنه بحمايه الامن القومي
التركي من هذه العناصر الارهابيه
ومصلحه مشتركه مع الشعب السوري ملايين
السوريين يا سيد الكريم دكتور يريدون ان
يعودوا لمدونهم وقراهم مستحيل ان تسال
اليوم سوري الا تريد ان تعود الى بلدك
سيقول نعم بكل تاكيد ولكن هذه العناصر
الارهابيه هجرت هؤلاء السوريين بالمناسبات
ماذا فعلت غير ذلك 400,000 مدني كردي سوري
اجرهم تنظيم بيكا هذا قصد هابي الذي يدعي
ضيفك ان تركيا لديها مشكله مع الاكراد يا
سيدي نصف الحكومه التركيه الان هم من
الاكراد رئيس الاستخبارات التركيه البطل
البطل هكذا الذي يقض مضاجع هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه هو من القوميه الكرديه نصف
الجيش التركي هو من الاكراد نصف الشعب
التركي هو من الاكراد اليوم في تركيا لا
يوجد عنصريه بين تركي وعربي وكوردي لحامله
المواطن لحامله الجنسيه التركيه كلهم
سواسيه امامه القانون التركي اي مواطن
يحمل الجنسيه التركيه يستطيع ان يكون
رئيسا للجمهوريه في تركيا مشكلتنا ليس
اردوغان وحلاقه ليست عن اردوغان وليذهب
اردوغان وليسقط اردوغان في الانتخابات
المقبله موضوعنا تركيا والامن القومي
التركي وليس اردوغان الامن القومي التركي
ستحميه الحكومه التركيه والجيش التركي
سواء كان اردوغان او لم يكن اردوغان الجيش
التركي العظيم لا يتحرك بناء لرغبات شخص
هو اردوغان على الاطلاق
هذه اهانه للجيش التركي الجيش التركي
يتحرك بناء لمصلحه الدوله لمصلحه الامن
القومي التركي لمصلحه العالم التركي
وحلفاء هذا العالم وبالتالي ايضا ساعيد
هذا المصطلح لانه يزعجهم العمليه العسكريه
التركيه القويه ستكون وشيكه جميل جدا غسان
ابراهيم السؤال المطروح برايك يعني لماذا
كل هذه المعارضه وهذه الضجه حول اي عمليه
عسكريه تركيه في الشمال او في الشرق او
لحمايه حدودها بس انا غسان بدي اسالك يعني
لماذا حلال على الروسي ان ياتي الاف
الكيلومترات
ويتمركز في شمال سوريا على الحدود التركيه
لماذا من حق الامريكي ان ياتي مش الاف
الاف عشرات الالاف من الاميال ويتمركز على
حدود تركيا وسوريا لماذا حلال على
الايراني ان ياتي من طهران ويحتل العراق
ويدخل سوريا ويتمركز في شمال سوريا ولماذا
حرام على تركيا التي لها الف كيلو متر
حدود مع سوريا انتم تنظف حدودك من هؤلاء
الارهابيين او من هذه الحركات الارهابيه
كيف ترد على من يقدمون مثل هذا الكلام
يعني حقيقه لانه تحمي حدودها من من كان
يعني جماعه داعش على الحدود لن تقوم باي
شيء ضدهم يعني اذا كان الامريكان قتلوا
قائد داعش كان في مناطق سيطره التركيه في
مناطق ادلب في اماكن وجود النصره النصره
تنظيم ارهابي لم تقم تركيا باي شيء معه بل
سير الدباباتها بحمايه داعش او بحمايه
النصره التي لا تختلف كثيرا عن داعش
ودعمتها في ادلب يعني عن اي ارهابي
يتحدثون هي لديهم مشكله مع الاكراد يا اخي
يقول ضيفه ان لا يوجد مشكله مع الاكره طيب
اين هم احزاب حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي كل
قياداتهم كل عناصرهم الذين كانوا في
البرلمان تم رفع عنهم الحصانه
لا توقفك هنا قبل نصف ساعه كانت احدى
البرلمانيات بهذا الوصف تهاجم الحكومه
التركيه على منبر البرلمان التركي رجاء
يعني جميل جميل
ويحاول ان يبرر لدى تركيا مش كلهم مع
الاكراد لديها مشكله مع كل المكونات تركيا
اليوم تتصرف بشكل لا يختلف كليا عن عن
ايران ايران وتركيا هم سبب البلاء في
سوريا
كلاهما دعم التطرف ايران دعامه الاسد
والجماعات المتطرفه من حزب الله وغيرها
وايضا ايجار اردوغان ودا عمل اسلامها
خربوا البلد والان يعود الاسد ورد قال لي
يعود الصداقه بينهم هذا يؤكد تناقضات
سياسات هذا الرجل لديه مشكله مع الارهاب
وهو الراعي الارهاب
بس يريد ان يريد ان رجاءا اذا بده يحكي
يتفضل اقرا ما معنى يعني بس بالنسبه
للموضوع
هدفها انتخابيه غير اردوغان يريد ان يدغدغ
مشاعر القوميين المتشددين من امثال من بعض
الاتراك الذين لديهم حقد على الكردي من
اجل ان يكسب اصوات وينجح في الانتخابات
الجيش التركي اليوم لم يعد جيشا مستقلا تم
اختراقه من قيادات محسوبه على اردوغان
ويوجهه في معارك ولكن في نهايه المطاف
الجيش التركي لا يستطيع ان يقوم باي عمليه
في سوريا الا من هو موافقه يا اما الروسي
وشهدنا ذلك ايام عفرين قدم اردوغان
المناطق التي كانت تسيطر عليها المعارضه
للروسي حتى يحصل على ضوء اخضر من الروس
ليدخل على عفرين اليوم مشكله اردوغان هي
مع جانب الامريكي امريكا من هي موجوده في
شرق البلاد وبدون ضوء اخضر من الامريكي لا
يجرا ان يقوم باي شيء يعني يبدو هذه
التهديدات التي يسمونها وشيكا ولا يفهمون
ما معنى كلمه وشيكا باللغه العربيه
يقولون وشيكا وبعد فتره يقولون في الوقت
المناسب والزمان مناسب وكانهم يكررون خطاب
الاسد وكانهم يظهرون مدى ضعفهم الاسد كانت
اسرائيل تضربوا ليلا النهار ويقول سوف نرد
في الوقت والمكان المناسب ونفس الشيء يفعل
اردوغان يهدد ثم ينكمش نحو الخلف وينتظر
موافقه امريكيه في النهايه يعلم انه لا
يجرا ان يقوم باي شيء بدون هذا الضوء
الاخضر يا الروسي يا الامريكي ولا حظنا
كيف انه في ايام ترامب تريد صغير صغير سبب
انهيار الليره التركيه الى اليوم هذا
الاقتصاد التركي في اسوا حالات وبالتالي
اردوغان يشعر ان الكثير من الاتراك لن
يصوتوا له
مشاكل خارجيه ويصدر عزماته نحو الخارج
تماما كما فعلت ايران صدرت ازماتها الى
الخارج واليوم تواجه ازمه داخليه وثور
داخليه ضد هذا النظام المتطرف ونفس الشيء
سوف يحدث في تركيا اخر انتخابات حدثت في
تركيا في كانت في اسطنبول وخسر اردوغان
وخسر حزمه هناك اضطر لي اعاده الانتخابات
وخسر مجددا الرجل لديه مشكله
لديهريا يريد ان يصفي حساباته في سوريا
الم يقول عده مرات انه سوف يصلي في الجامع
الاموي اليوم يحاول ارضاء الاسد من اجل ان
يدخل الى راضي السوريه اعتقد اليوم هناك
حدث مهم جدا في سوريا الانتفاضه التي بدات
في السويداء هي صفعه لكل من يفكر بالتطبيع
مع الاسد واولهم واولهم من ادعى انه صديق
للشعب السوري هو اردوغان اليوم الذي صفح
حساباته مع الاسد واصبح همه فقط احتلال
اراضي من سوريا الاراضي التي تحتلها تركيا
يا سيدي يتم التعليم فيها باللغه التركيه
والبريد بريد تركي والاتصالات اتصالات
اتصالات تركيا كل ذلك محاوله لاقتطاع هذه
الاراضي السوريه الكنا في سوريا عندنا
احتلال في الجنوب اسمه اسرائيل اليوم
عندنا احتلال في الشمال اسمها تركيا فعن
اي محاوله لمساعده الشعب السوري يقول انه
يريد ان يدخل تلك المناطق لاعاده اللاجئين
سوف يجبرهم للعوده اجبار بالقوه لان
السوري لن يقبل ابن دمشق ليذهب الى منطقه
غير منطقه في اردوغان لديه وهم يقام منطقه
يسميها بالمنطقه الامره يعني ذلك يريد طرد
بعض الفصائل الكرديه من تلك المناطق
لاقامت هذه المشاريع التي هي تعتبر تغيير
ديموغرافي تماما كما فعلت ايران في الجانب
جميل جدا وصلت الفكره بطوله افريقيا
ستتصرف بالنافس عقليه روسيا وايران وهي
ليست احسن منهم بالاسوء منهم هؤلاء لم
يدعوا صداقه الشعب السوري هي ادعت صداقه
الشعب السوري وخاذلت السوريين كما خذلت كل
من دعاه
الارض الارض يكذب هذا الكلام تركيا مع
الشاعر السوري
مع تركيا وتركيا مع الشعب السوري ومن يريد
ان يرى هذه الحقيقه فعليه ان يذهب الى
مناطق الشمال السوري المحرره من التنظيمات
الارهابيه هم لا يريدون ان يروا الصوره
الايجابيه اليوم التي تقدمها تركيا الشمال
السوري انا قبل ايام كنت في ادلب انا قبل
ايام كنت في ادلب ورحيت جانبيه المحبه
والتعاطف من الشعب السوري اللاجئين الذين
يعانون رغم هذه المعاناه التحيات التي
ارسلوها الرئيس اردوغان سواء معي او مع
الوفد
التركيين في الشمال اقاموا الدنيا ولم
يقعدوها عندما شاهدوا اردوغان يتودد الى
الاسد هذه الحركه التي قام بها السوريون
في الشمال السوري كانت لخدمه تركيا وكانت
لخدمه الموقف التركي واظهرت موقف تركي
امام العالم انه موقف قوي ان اليوم ان
اليوم تركيا لا تريد هذه العلاقه ان تعود
مع النظام السوري بالمجان وبالتالي اخذت
الدعم الشعبي منها السوريين الذين تظاهروا
في الشمال السوري ورفعوا الاعلام التركيه
في تلك المظاهرات مؤيدين لتركيا طالبينها
طالبين منها عدم تغيير الموقع
الدعم الشعبي السوري كان قوي
للمفاوضين الاتراك على الطاوله هذه الصوره
الايجابيه لا يريدونها وزير الداخليه
التركي في ادلب كنت مع وزير الداخليه
ورايت كميه التعاطف والمحبه من قبل الشعب
السوري في نحن في ادلب تركيا تفتتح
المشاريع التنمويه في ادلب تركيا تفتتح
المشاريع التنمويه في ادلب للمدنيين
مستشفيات قرى مدارس جامعه في هذه اللحظات
حصل تفجير اسطنبول الارهابي قبل ايام في
شارع الاستقلال في نفس الوقت تركيا تبني
هناك والتنظيمات الارهابيه تفجر في قلب
اسطنبول هذا هو الفرق امام العالم انا
اريد ان اقول وارد على عده نقاط ادعاها
همم من لندن اولا القضيه ليست قضيه ضوء
اخضر روسي اخضر امريكي
لماذا لا نقول ان روسيا وامريكا تبيعكم
على الطاوله مع التركي تبيعكم ليست قضيه
الفصائل الميليشيات هذه الشرذمه من
التنظيمات الارهابيه في الشمال السوري
القضيه ليست ضو اخضر تركيا اليوم دوله
قويه عظمى في المنطقه روسيا دوله قويه
عظمى في المنطقه شئنا اتفقنا مع اختلفنا
امريكا كذلك وبالتالي اليوم تركيا تجلس مع
الامريكي ومع الروسي من باب انديه وليس من
باب الضعف امريكا تبيع التنظيمات
الارهابيه وليس تعطي ضوء اخضر البيت
الابيض يؤكد يؤكد حق تركيا في الدفاع عن
نفسها قبل ايام باعت الميليشيات تعلن
تقليص دورياتها في شمال سوريا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قبل يومين وبالتالي
القضيه بيع وليس اخضر اردوغان نعم صديق
للشعب السوري لولا تركيا ولولا الدعم
التركي الذي ما زال مستمرا الى الان ما
كان هناك وضع مستقر في الشمال السوري
تركيا الدوله الوحيده الان في العالم في
العالم التي ما زالت تد الشعب السوري
سياسيا وميداميا واغافيا وتنمويا الوحيده
في العالم ولا احد يستطيع ان يكذب ذلك
يكذب الحقيقه يقول التعليم في الشمال
السوري باللغه التركيه يعني ما هذا الكذب
انا شخصيا ذهبت الى تلك المناطق وبيدي
والزعد الكتب التي تعلم اللغه العربيه في
المدارس ما هذا الكذب وما هذه القضيه اعود
لقضيه الضوء الاخضر
من احد في هذا الكوكب لا قبل اردوغان ولا
بعد اردوغان تركيا نفذت اثنين 10 عمليه
عسكريه منذ ال 74 حتى ال 2002 عمليه
السلام في قبرص عمليه الفولات الشماليه
العراق عمليه المطرقه عمليه فجر هذه في
العراق عمليه اضنه اضنه التي حشدت فيها
تركي الجيش التركي على الحدود السوريه
والطرا النظام السوري في ذلك الوقت وخضع
للاراده التركيه ووقع اتفاقيه اضنه التي
تسمح للجيش التركي بالدخول الى الاراضي
السوريه وملاحقه التهديدات الارهابيه
ديت الشمس شماليه العراق عمليه درع الفرات
عمليه غصن الزيتون عمليه المخلب عمليه نبع
السلامه عمليه درع الربيع وعمليه المخلب
المستمره الان في الشمال السوري سيف
المخلب السيف لاطهحح جمله قلتها ان
العمليه التركيه دعني اقول مصطلح اخر يعني
ليست وشيكه هي بدات فعليه يا دكتور فيصل
هي بدات المغرب السيف بدا بدا القصف الجوي
التركي بدا وبالتالي هذا التمهيد الجو
الكبير الذي يحصل للمره الاولى بالعلم
العسكري هو تمهيد
للقضايا البريه وبالتالي بهذه الاسلحه
تركيا تستخدم اسلحتها اليوم انظر هذه
تركيا اليوم تبني اسلحتها وتستخدم اسلحتها
لا الاسلحه الامريكيه ولا الاسلحه الروسيه
هم يقاتلون اليوم
تركيا الجديده تركيا التي اثبتت موقفها في
الساحه الدوليه والاقليميه رغم 20 سنه من
المحاربه التكنولوجيه والعسكريه والامنيه
والسياسيه والاعلاميه ولكن تركيا اثبتت
موق الاستخبارات التركيه دعني اقول لك
سؤال بس خليني اسالك سؤال طيب اذا كانت
تركيا بكل هذه القوه وتستطيع وكذا لماذا
تذهب
وتتودد او تتوازي يعني كي تقابل واحد مثل
بشار او واحد مثل هذا النظام اللي مش قادر
يخرج من الجحر قبل ايام تحدث بعض السوريين
قال خمسه يعني 23 مليون سوري يعيشون في
ريجار في ريكار طيب يعني هل يعقل ان تركيا
بعد كل هذه القوه تتودد لرئيس منتهي
الصلاحيه مدعوس مذموم لا يست- اا جالس في
جحر كالجر لا يستطيع ان يخرج فلماذا
تتوتنهام لماذا يستطيع ان يفيدكم هذا
النظام المنهار الذي لا يجد لا هم له الا
تجاره المخدرات وتجاره النفط وقت قتل
السوريين وتهجيرهم ليش رايحين له اذا
عندكم القوه
ماذا ينفعنا هذا الامر لا ينفعنا شيء وبال
هل يعقل اليوم هل يعقل اليوم ان تركيا
تذهب الى النظام السوري المنهار والذي
وصفته بما وصفته غير منطقي ان تذهب تركيا
على الاحتكاك تركيا اليوم تضع الشروط على
النظام السوري وهذه الشروط هي لخدمه
السوريين ولخدمه الاتراك شروط عديده دعني
اقراها لك لانها مكتوبه وحساسه على النظام
السوري اذا اراد ان هو يصحح علاقاته مع
تركيا وانا استطيع ان اقول لك ان النظام
السوري هو الذي ارسل رسائل ايجابيه عبر
الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه للتردد الى تركيا
وليس العكس ولكن الذي يميز اردوغان انه
جريء انه يخرج الى الاعلام ويقول وهم
جبناء لا يتحدثون مع شعوبهم لا في هذه
الدوله العربيه ولا في تلك الدوله العربيه
هم الجبناء اردوغان القوي الذي يخرج واقول
بكل جراءه يتجرا ويقول انا اجلس معه وليس
كل من جلست معه يعني هو حليفك وليس من
جلست معه يعني انه قريب اليك وليس كل من
جلست معه انه صاحب ثقه على النظام السوري
انا اقوله هنا يسمعون اذا اراد ان يصلح
العلاقه مع تركيا اولا عليه ان يتصرف في
مسؤوليه وعقليه الدوله وليس عقليه
الميليشيات عليه انظر بس دقيقه بس دقيقه
عليه عليه هي شروط تركيه عليه تقديم
ضمانات امنيه لتركيا ضمانات كبرى عليه ان
يحمي الحدود
التركيه هل يستطيع ان يفعل ذلك كلا يستطيع
عليه ان يسمح للمسار السياسي وهنا النقطه
الحساسه ان يسمح للمسار السياسي في سوريا
ان ينطلق ويصل لنتيجه مع المعارضه السوريه
يعني تركيا لن تتخلى عن شروط الجزيره شروط
تعجيزيه عاجز عن تنفيذها هو عاجز عن تامين
رغيف خبز للمواطنين في المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها عاجز عن تامين كبه الذين في تحت
السيطراته وبالتالي من المنطق ان تاتي
دوله كبر قويه في المنطقه تركيا لتتصالح
هي تبادر بالتصالح مع هذا النظام الساقط
اقتصاديا وعسكريا واميا واخلاقيا وفي كل
النواحي تركيا لا تتودد لاحد وابدعني اقول
امر نخرج من دائره ان نظهر الشعب السوري
دائما انه شعب متخلف وانه شعب جاهل وانه
شعب يعني فقط مظلوم ويتباكى علينا ان نخرج
بقى القضيه الحقيقيه ان الشعب السوري
اليوم بدا يتعلم السياسه وبدا يخرج ليكون
سياسيا في المرحله المقبله قادم قادر على
بناء دوله حقيقيه وبالتالي الشعب السوري
قادر على هذا الامر تركيا اليوم هي الدوله
الوحيده واكرر التي تقف سياسيا في ظهر
المعارضه على طاوله الحوار مع الكبار
الذين العمليه
لا لا قصدي والعمليه العسكريه هي جزء من
الاستراتيجيه التركيه لدعم السوريين بكل
تاكيد ستدعم السوريين العمليه العسكريه
ستامن دعني اعطي مثال نبع السلام اخر
عمليا ماذا فعلت نبع السلام في الشمال
السوري اعاد التركي بهذه العمليه 200 الف
مدني سوري الى تلك المناطق نصفهم من
الاكراد لم تقتلهم تركيا اجر التركيه 250
200 2500 عمليه طبيه مجانيه هذه خلال سنه
واحده خلال سنه واحده 1000 عمليه ولاده
50,000 تلميذ يدرسون في تلك المناطق
بحمايه تركيه باللغه العربيه 450 مدرسه في
تلك المناطق تركيا تبني ولا تدمر كما فعل
الاخرون في المناطق السوريه
الوشيكه او المزرعه سميها ما شئت
هي ليست فقط كما تقول يعني
للتحرش بالفصائل الكرديه او من هذا الكلام
ذكر لك الكثير من العمليات هل تستطيع ان
تنكر ان تركيا هذه ليست اول عمليه لها ذكر
لك كم عمليات 10 عمليه
واخرهم انت بتعرف نبع السلام وغسل الزيتون
و درع الفرات يعني كل الناس بتذكرون غسان
غسان طيب لماذا انتم تعارضون مثل هذه
العمليات التركيه يعني انا وصلنا الى
الكثير من الاسئله تقول لك انت تدافع عن
ميليشيا انفصاليه عراقيه كرديه تحتل ثلث
اراضي سوريا وتسرق نفطها وقمحاها
ومسؤوله عن تهجير مئات الالاف من العرب
وايضا من الاكراد وحرق وتجريف قراهم وهذا
موثق بتقارير العفو الدوليه وهيما الرايس
واتش وتمارس تكريت لمناطق عربيه خالصه
بقول لك يعني احدهم مدينه منبج ماذا تفعل
ميليشيا اوجلان وصوره في منب مدينه
البحتري وابو فراس الحمداني والبحتري لا
تقول لي اوجلان سوريا وتفرض هذه
الميليشيات الكرديه التي تريد تركيه طردها
بهذه العمليه القادمه يعني وطرد عفوا هذا
كفيل بان يعيد السوريين الى مناطقهم ويعيد
السوريين الى المناطق التي تحتلها هذه
الميليشيات من اطراف دير الزور الى الرقه
والحسكه ومنبج حتى تل رفعت ويل العرب
وتفرض ثقافه مناهج دراسيه ايه سوريا بدل
المناهج التي تفرضها هذه الجماعات التي
تريد تركيا استئصالها كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام
يعني اذا كان بغض النظر عن صحه هذا الكلام
الفكره هي باختصار يعني تركيا هي حريصه
على شان السوريا تركيا هي التي سلمت كل
مناطق التي كانت تسيطر عليها المعارضه
السوريه للروسي مقابل الحصول على كم ضيعه
في عفرين يعني هذا شيء يثبت ان تركيا ما
تريد ان تفعله ليس حرصا على السوريين وليس
حرصا على العرب السوريين ضد الكرد
السوريين هي تريد ايقاع ما بين العربي
والكردي نعم قصد لديها اخطاء نعم اسد يجب
ان تغير من سياساتها ويجب ويجب ويجب ولكن
في النهايه قصد هم سوريين بينما تركيا
ليست سوريا ايضا ضيفك يقول ان تركيا قامت
ب 12 عمليه هذا يؤكد فشل كل هذه العمليات
لو كانت العمليه الاولى ناجحه لا محتاجه
13 عام 14
كمل دقيقه
فلو انا اللي عم اقول له اللي بدها تعمل
بالشمال السوري هو اللي عملته في الشمال
قبرص لاحظ ماذا فعلت دخلت واحتلت جزء من
قبرص وتركته بالقوه وجعلته دوله غير معترف
بها من احد نفس الشيء تعتمد على النصره
وبعض جماعات الاسلاميه الارهابيه للسيطره
على الشمال وتستخدمهم كايضا جزء جديد
مستترك من قبل الاتراك في سوريا يعني اذا
كانت المشكله لدى تركيا مع اوجلان فتتفاهم
مع اوجلان اللي موجود عندها وليس مع
الفصائل الكرديه السوريه وثانيا اذا كان
خلقها على يعني حقيقه على السوريين الا ما
بعدنا ما نسينا سؤال اردوغان وجماعته
قالوا انه لو انه الاسد بقاتل الاكراد
السوريين لو وقفنا معه يعني هذا يؤكد انه
عقدتهم فقط مع تلك الفصائل سميها ما شئت
لدى عقده عقده اردوغان وهدف برده جان هو
القتال تلك الفصائل وليس لخدمه السوريين
وثانيا في في تلك المناطق التي يسميها
استقرار ادلب وغيرها مناطق لا يوجد لها
فيها خدمات لا يوجد فيها استقرار فيها
فصائل اسلاميه متطرفه تستخدم نفس اسلوب
الاسد سجون وقمع وغيرها من كل هذه الامور
ومع ذلك تركيا تقف مع تلك الفصائل دون ان
تقوم باي عمل بناء تحتل وتتركها مناطق
فوضويه اليوم تركيا بمصر الكثير من
السوريين في اسوا مراحلها والسبب في ذلك
ان اردوغان غير من كل سياساته خدع الجميع
وانقلب على الجميع يريد ان يتفاهم مع
الاسد اسد رجل منهار نظام منهار يتحكم به
الايراني والروسي والجميع ومع ذلك يقول
لهم مستعدين للتفاهم معك اذا سمحت لنا
بالدخول لمقاتله الاكلات شو نفكر الاسد
صاحب قرار حتى تروح تتفاهم معه
دوجان يبدو فعلا انه الرجل منفصل عن
الواقع خليه الاسد هيقول له روح غسان خليه
خليك بس شوي خليك شويه خليك شويه هذه نقطه
مهمه جدا اريد ان اوجهها لا حمزه تكن نقطه
مهمه يعني انتم اللي بيشوفكم عم بتتقربوا
من الاسد بتفكروا انه هذا الاسد ما شاء
الله يعني ماسك بخيوط اللعبه يا زلمه هو
قادر يمسك الخيط اللي بتعرفه يعني قادر
يمسك الخيط اللي بلش نحكي هلا لما نكون
رايحين له يا سيدي انت تعلم الاسد انت
تعلم
ان الشرط الاساسي التي الذي وضعته اسرائيل
عندما قالت لبشار ونظامه قالت له
سنحميك من السقوط لكن سلم شرق سوريا لقد
فسلم شرق سوريا بقمحها وماؤها
سلمها
ليسد
سلمها والامريكان نفس العمليه
تراهنون انت تعلم ان الرسن
والرسل الاسدي بيد اسرائيل واسرائيل لم
تسمح لتركيا لا بتطهير المنطقه ولا بشان
عمليات والى ما هنالك البعض يقول لك انت
قارئ جيد يا حمزه
الامريكان والصهاينه عندما وجدوا مسمار
جحا في سوريا والعراق هل تعتقد انهم
سيستغلون عنه بسهوله حتى لو كانت تركيا
الان قويه نسبيا و و و و اسرائيل لن تسمح
لكم بالذهاب ضد الاكراد ممكن حركات بسيطه
لكن هذا المكان اا اسد ليست كيانا كرديا
اسد مشروع ايراني
مشروع اسرائيلي مشروع امريكي مشروع روسي
انتم تواجهون العديد من القوه التي تدعم
هذه الميليشيات اللي انت مفكرها انه والله
ما نفوتهم شيلها كيف ترد قبل ان ارد على
هذا السؤال المهم جدا اريد ان اوجه تحيه
كبيره واجلال بضيفك في لندن لانه اعترف
اعترافا امام الملايين ان اليوم تركيا
تريد ان تفعل بالشمال السوري كما فعلت بي
الشمال القبرصي وبالتالي تنميه قبرص اليوم
ستصبح دوله
انا اتحدث عن الثانيه نتحدث عن الساميه
في قبرص جامعه في قبر السياحه في قبرص
انسان يعيش بكهرباء وماء وحياه في قبرص
حياه من النعيم وبالتالي تركيا نعم سوريا
للشعب السوري ولا القضيه السوريه على
الاطلاق من باع الشعب السوري هو النظام
السوري الذي تحالف مع هذا وذاك وقتل
واستخدم البراميل المتفجره اعيد او اكرر
ان تركيا اليوم ما زالت هي الدوله الوحيده
التي تقف الى جانب الشعب السوري والرئيس
الوحيد في العالم الذي يتكلم بالقضيه
السوريه حتى اليوم هو الرئيس اردوغان
تركيا
من مصلحتها الاستراتيجيه تريح راسها تخرج
من سوريا وتبني هذا السور وتنتهي القضيه
لماذا لا تفعل ذلك لانها صاحبه مبدا تقف
مع الشعب السوري ولكن الوقوف بحكمه الوقوف
في وليس الوقوف بغيرعقل طيب عن العمليه
العسكريه السؤال الذي
طرح مهم جدا النظام السوري هو الذي باع
نفسه
لائيل في الجولان منذ عشرات السنين اذا
اليوم كان هو فعلا يريد ان يحرر الاراضي
ويخرج المحتل التركي فليتفضل اولا الى
الجولان انا ساكون معه ضد اسرائيل ثم ضد
تركيا تمام طيب فليذهب
اسرائيل اسرائيل يا سيدي الورقه رسم اسد
ليس بيد امريكا بيد اسرائيل اسرائيل
امريكا بالمناسبه الكلام للسوريين
العارفين بقول لك اسد والاسد اسد والاسد
اذا سقط الاول سقط الثاني واثنين مشروع
اسرائيلي هذا النظام ان تركيا تحارب الكل
يحارب الكل في سوريا سواء كان النظام
بمناسبه قبل قليل تم قصف مواقع للنظام في
جنوبيه
وحلفاء تركيا وبالتالي تركيا لم تتقرب مع
احد اليوم تركيا تحارب العالم في الشمال
السوري هناك مخطط سايكس بيكو جديد تمام
سكس فيكو جديد
قبل 100 سنه اسقط السلطان عبد الحميد
الثاني قبل 100 سنه تقريبا ومرروا سايكس
بيكو واخذوا فلسطين للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
انا استطيع ان اقول لك اليوم مع تركيا
الجديده التي بنيت على مدى 20 عاما بحكمه
وقوه مع الاسلحه التركيه والقوه
الدبلوماسيه التي وصلت اليها تركيا
والدليل الاوكرانيا والدليل اليوم الرئيس
الصومالي شكل تركي على مساعدها والدليل
الوقوف التركي مع الحلفاء بقوه في قطر في
ليبيا في اذربيجان الان في اذربيجان هناك
مناورات ضخمه تركيا اثريه هذه الصوره
اليوم هذه الصوره اليوم وبالتالي تركيا لا
تسال على احد عسكريه اليوم تركيا تحارب
سايكس بيكو جديد في المنطقه لتقسيم سوريا
ثم يعني
هل انتم
قادرون على مواجهه القوه الاسرائيليه في
شمال تركيا
هذه الصوره قبل ايام منظمه الدول التركيه
تركيا ليست وحدها اليوم تركي اصبحت قوه
اقليميه عظمى عسكريه وسياسيا ودبلوماسيا
تركيا ستحارب المشروع الاسرائيلي وكل من
دعم هذا المشروع في المنطقه لو التقفلان
مع فلان دعك من الصور البروتوكوليه يا
دكتور فيصل تركيا ليست مع سايكس بيكو جديد
تقوده اسرائيل في سوريا او في لبنان او في
الاردن او في العراق تركيا ستحارب هذا
المشروع عبر جيشها وقوتها الدبلوماسيه
وقوتها الاقتصاديه بنقطه الاخيره الضيف
نسيت اسمه من لندن قال عن الوضع الاقتصادي
يعني اخبره ان الاقتصاد التركي حقق نمو
3.9% خلال الربع الثالث
التوقعات الدوليه التوقعات الدوليه موجز
لست انا وليس اردوغان وليس وزير الماليه
التي تحدث تقول ان الاقتصاد التركي
نقطه اخيره التضخم يقولون التضخم في تركيا
التضخم بدا يتراجع انظروا التضخم بدا
يتراجع وبالتالي القضيه الاقتصاديه عالميه
لا نصور ان فقط تركيا تعاني من اجل
جميل جدا غسان غسان
البعض يقول ان يعني خلينا البعض يقول ان
ما تسعى تركيا الان لاجتافي او لطفه في
شمال سوريا لا يخص تركيا وسوريا وحدها بل
يخص المنطقه باكملها هذه الميليشيات او
هذه القضيه قضيه الميريشيات الكرديه التي
تريد تركيه القضاء عليها كما يقولون لك هي
السكين التي يتم من خلالها الان تقطيع دول
عربيه اربع بدا التقطيع بالعراق من خلال
هذه السكين اللي تريد
القضاء عليها بدا التقطيع بالعراق وانتقل
الى سوريا ووصل الان الى ايران بالمناسبه
نحن نعلم ان ايران كانت من اكبر ال-
المستثمرين بالمشروع الكردي في سوريا
وكانت حتى اوجلان بالمناسبه استخبارات
سوريا تقول له حتى اذلان مش نحن اللي
جبناه على سوريا ايران فرض وجلال على
السوريين الان ايران بعد ان تحرك الاكراد
ضدها في الداخل الايراني بدات تخفف من
لهجتها ضد الاتراك ويمكن ان تسمح لهم
بالدخول الى شمال سوريا ضد الميلشيات
الكرديه لان السكين الكرديه بدا التتار
الجميع كيف ترد عليهم مش كلامه
يعني شوف من بين من التناقدات الذي تم ذكر
الان انه السكين الكرديه حسب وصف كون انه
هي
اسرائيليين ما طول عمره هو صديق
للاسرائيليين عمل قصه وانسحب من احد
الاجتماع
تركيا باسرائيل من قطعت والسفاره
الاسرائيليه في تركيا من قطعت تركيا اول
دوله من طبع مع اسرائيل فما بدنا نزود على
بعض يعني قصه هاي كلمه اسرائيل صارت
ممزوجه كثير وبايخه كثير وما عاد حدا
يتقبل لها اردوغان اللي عم يعملوا اليوم
بحجه اسرائيل ما بين ما بينبلع يعني اي
دوله ثانيه فيها تاجر بقضيه اسرائيل الا
الا تركيا يعني تحديدا تركيه هي قلبا
وروحا وعلاقه وتعاون عسكري واقتصادي
والتجاري مع اسرائيل
لعبت على القضيه السوريه فهذه الشعب مثلا
من يحمي قصد والمليشيات الكرديه التي تهدد
تركيا في الشمال والشرق السوريين اليست
امريكا يعني امريكا يعني اسرائيل امريكا
يعني اسرائيل هل تستطيع ان ان تنكر ذلك
الامريكيه
يعني غساله
كلما كلما حاولت تركيا ان تضرب هذه
الجامعهات اه تخرج لنا امريكا لتقول لا
نستطيع ان نضحي بقصد وجماعته الكرديه
لانها معنا داعش
بشرفك والله
في امريكا ضحت فيهم بس السؤال المطروح
السؤال فعلا يرد هل فعلا هل فعلا امريكا
تدعم اسد والميليشيات الكرديه بحجه انه
تساعدها بالداع اشياء زلمه قال امريكا ضد
داعش كيف ترد
باختصار امريكا لها مصالح انا ماني من
مؤيدين لا امريكا ولا روسيا ولا ايران انا
ضد اي وجود اجنبي في سوريا لانها في نهايه
المطاف تركت الاسد
على كرسي في قصر معزول
وخلت الشعب السوري يدفع الثمن باختصار
امريكا موجوده هناك مصالحها تركيا نفس
الشيء بدها تدخل الفرق بين تركيا وامريكا
امريكا ما حدش يتقطع جزء من سوريا
وتضم ولايه امريكيه بالتركيه تركيه فيها
تعمل الشيء اعمل لك هذا الشيء احتل جزء من
قبرص ودمته بدها تحتل جزء من العراق بدها
تعيد الاحلام العثمانيه ضيفك عم يحكي لك
عن ايام احد السلاطين وغيرها من القصص
باختصاص باختصار تركيا لديها مشكله
انتخابيه وتحديدا لدى اردوغان يريد ان
ياخذ
اهتمام الشعب التركي الذي هو شعب عاطفي
مثل باقي شعوب المنطقه ويقول لهم الارهاب
يا اخي الارهاب عم يسرح ويمرح باسطنبول ما
هو اردوغان تارك الباب مفتوح لكل اسلاميين
العالم المتطرفين يجوا على اسطنبول ويوجهن
مرعي على سوريا مره على ليبيا مره على
مناطق اخرى العمليه العسكريه اللي بجزمتها
هو زعيم دوله قويه وعندها سلاح وعندها
قدره لكانت تتقدمت تركيا قاعده محميه
بقاعده لك الامريكيين يعني مثلا امريكي
موجوده موجوده
بسرعه يا سيدي الامريكان وهذه الجماعات
التي يدافع عنها الامريكان في شمال وشرق
سوريا الجامعات الكرديه الامريكان وغيرهم
يقولون لولا هذه الجماعات لا كانت داعش
الان تسيطر على كل المنطقه
يسيطر على كل المنطقه فكيف يعني الارهاب
لعمله واحده الجيش التركي هو الجيش الوحيد
النظامي في العالم الذي حارب تنظيم داعش
اليوم الجمعه اليوم تركيا تركيا
مشاريع اسرائيل شرقيه المتوسطه
مشروع تقسيم العراق الاسرائيلي مشروع
تقسيم سوريا الاسرائيلي اليوم تركيا ليست
على علاقات طيبه مع اسرائيل رغم هذه
السيارات
الى تركيا
اسلاميه
قويه التي تقدمه
واحده
العمليه العسكريه قادمه وستنجح اشكرك
اشكرك انجح
عمليا اشكرك شكرا
ضيفنا من لندن غسان ابراهيم وفي الاستوديو
حمزه نلتقي المقبل
الى اللقاء يعطيكم العافيه يا جماعه
[موسيقى]